Salut la Team Mentalo ! Ça y est, c'est la reprise. Durant environ un mois je vous ai mis des énigmes sur la chaîne YouTube.
Vous y avez répondu, bravo à tous ceux qui ont trouvé des énigmes.
Bravo à ceux qui ont résisté à la tentation de donner la réponse dans les commentaires.
Il reste encore 4 mois à tenir pour réussir le défi du Mental Vlog, qui est, je vous le rappelle,
faire une vidéo par jour pendant un an depuis le 1er janvier, où j'ai lancé tout ça, jusqu'au 31 décembre qui se rapproche !
Dans cette vidéo je vous donne toutes les nouveautés qu'il va y avoir sur la chaîne,
les petits changements, parce qu'il y en a, et je vous parle aussi de 2017 et de quelques surprises.
Donc t'es obligé de rester jusqu'à la fin !
Premier changement: il n'y aura plus de calendrier sur la chaîne.
Alors, le calendrier il est quand même simple. C'est une vidéo tous les jours à 17H la semaine et à 11H le week-end.
Mais jusqu'ici je donnais un thème aux jours de la semaine.
Le lundi c'était plutôt le vlog, le mardi je mentalisais quelqu'un...
Le problème c'est qu'en y réfléchissant cet été j'ai trouvé que ça me bridais.
Alors je garde tous les mêmes concepts: mentaliser de gens, vous faire du vlog, vous donner des astuces de mentalisme,
faire des masterclass, faire des explications de mentalisme...
Mais il y aura pas de jours définis, ce sera aussi en fonction de ce que j'ai de mieux à vous dire.
Ça permettra aussi sur un masterclass qui est vraiment très intéressant de la faire sur 2 jours par exemple.
Ça va également me permettre de commencer une nouvelle série, un nouveau thème.
Qui est "j'ai lu". Oh chouette de la lecture !
"J'ai lu" oui, mais toujours appliqué au mentalisme. Peut-être une ou deux fois par mois.
Dans les jours ou semaines à venir il va y avoir d'autre changements.
Il va y avoir de la musique dédiée par un créateur qui fait ça, vraiment de la musique.
On s'est rencontré plusieurs fois, on se revoit là très bientôt pour finaliser tout ça.
Il va y avoir également un nouveau logo pour cette chaîne.
Alors là c'est pareil, je travaille avec un graphiste pour ça, il est en train de finir le logo.
J'espère qu'il vous plaira, je ne vous dis pas encore ce que c'est.
Et je travaille également avec un mec qui fait du motion design, qui est entrain de créer une intro pour la chaîne.
C'est une intro très courte, ça dure juste quelques secondes, mais ça permettait de mettre en valeur le logo.
Je sais pas exactement quand est-ce que ces 3 choses vont être mises en place.
Puisque là forcément je dépends de trois personnes différentes mais je ne veux pas leur mettre la pression, je préfère que ce soit très bien fait.
Et en parlant de logo vous serez peut-être amené de temps en temps à voir ce logo là.
Qui est le logo dont je me sers pour mon nouveau spectacle.
Tout du moins, à la tournée de rodage.
Vous le savez, cette année j'écris le nouveau spectacle qui va être lancé
en début d'année prochaine, en janvier 2017 en tournée de rodage.
Dont l'affiche est d'ailleurs ici.
Et je vais le roder donc en tournée durant une période de 6 mois, d'ailleurs il y a toutes les dates qui vont arriver sur le site internet.
Vous avez le lien dans le descriptif.
Evidemment !
Mais l'année prochaine, tout en faisant ces dates là de spectacle en tournée, je vais continuer les vidéos sur la chaîne.
Je ne sais pas encore tout mais je sais une chose c'est que je ne vais pas refaire une vidéo par jour pendant un an.
Puisque ça c'était un défi. Si je continue le défi n'a plus de sens, en fait, en lui même.
Donc je vais faire moins de vidéo. Peut-être une, deux par semaine.
Ce qui est sûr c'est qu'une fois par mois il y aura une vidéo spéciale
où j'ai déjà le concept et j'ai déjà parlé avec des personnes, pour travailler avec moi, qui sont OK.
Donc ça, ce sera un gros format mensuel.
Et puis peut-être une ou deux par semaine sur des choses qui ressemblent plus à ce qu'on fait aujourd'hui.
Mais qui, j'espère, seront encore plus produites, plus écrites et plus créatives.
Et pour terminer, les objectifs.
Vous savez qu'à 50 000 abonnés, j'avais dit en début que je ferai un Mental Up, une rencontre, un espèce de Meet Up,
où je testerai des morceaux du nouveau spectacle avec vous pour avoir votre avis.
Ce sera dans 15 000 abonnés, du moins au moment où je fais cette vidéo, puisque là on est à 35 000.
Quand j'ai lancé cette chaine le premier janvier, je m'étais dit: "Ah ! Si à la fin de l'année j'ai 10 000 ou 12 000 abonnés, ce sera pas mal, ça fera 1000 abonnés par mois, ce sera super."
Et j'ai eu la grande surprise qu'on soit déjà 35 000 aujourd'hui ! C'est juste énorme !
Donc mon nouvel objectif, au-delà des 50 000 ce palier là pour faire le Mental Up ensemble, c'est d'atteindre les 100 000 abonnés.
J'ai un rêve secret, je vous le dis vraiment, il me parait difficilement possible... Mais ce serait tellement beau !
C'est qu'au 31 décembre, on ai atteint les 100 000 abonnés.
Et de se dire que durant toute la durée du défi, on a été 100 000 comme ça, à se retrouver dans la Team Mentalo.
C'est un vrai palier les 100 000, et je me dis que si je les atteins avant le 31 décembre, dans ces cas là je vais peut-être réfléchir même différemment pour l'année prochaine,
à quelque chose de très sérieux en fait pour YouTube.
Pas "très sérieux" dans le fond, mais dans la forme, dans l'organisation, pour me consacrer en fait à mes vidéos YouTube.
Voilà. Vous connaissez maintenant mon défi ultime, mon but ultime qui est j'espère aussi, votre but à vous.
Parce que, une chose est sûr, c'est que c'est pas tout seul que ça avance.
C'est vraiment grâce à vous depuis le départ, j'en ai bien conscience et je vous en remercie.
Et si vous le voulez, ensemble, on peut essayer d'atteindre les 100 000 avant le 31 décembre.
Je vous l'ai dit en début de vidéo, j'ai aussi quelques surprises à vous annoncer pour les jours à venir, les semaines à venir, les mois à venir.
Dans les surprises... Il y a des mots comme "Poisson Fécond" !
Que j'ai eu la chance d'aller rencontrer à Grenoble où on a fait une vidéo ensemble.
C'est vraiment quelqu'un de très très très très bien.
Merci beaucoup à lui !
Mais on a également préparé quelque chose avec Max Bird.
J'ai préparé aussi quelque chose avec Noam.
J'ai fait une vidéo sur la chaine d' "Emmymakeuppro", qui va sortir sur sa chaine à elle, là par contre.
Et très très prochainement, c'est-à-dire demain, je vous présente une vidéo que j'ai faite avec Romain.
Romain de la chaine "TechNews&Test".
Elle sort demain cette vidéo.
Elle est un petit peu longue, parce qu'elle est différente, et de temps en temps il y a aura des vidéos différentes comme ça.
C'est-à-dire que je vais à la rencontre de Romain, je vais chez lui.
Donc la première partie de la vidéo est un petit peu en mode vlog.
Et après on est tous les deux sur le canapé, c'est très conversationnel.
Comme ça on apprend aussi des choses sur Romain. C'est un mec excellent en fait !
Il est juste très drôle et très sympathique.
Et ensuite, évidemment, j'essaie de le mentaliser.
Et ça, vous verrez ça demain, si j'y arrive ou pas.
Voilà. Une vidéo différente.
J'espère avoir vos avis aussi dessus demain. Si ce style là vous plait, j'en ferai plus régulièrement.
Merci à vous d'être ici.
C'est la rentrée. Vous allez déchiré, je vais déchiré, on va déchiré.
En tout cas c'est ce que je nous souhaite à nous tous.
Les vacances c'est fini.
Tiens, d'ailleurs, dites moi dans les commentaires où vous étiez en vacances.
J'aimerai bien voir. Si ça se trouve on était peut-être au même endroit à des moments.
On va voir ça, vous me le mettez dans les commentaires, je lirai ça.
N'oubliez pas de mettre un petit pouce, qui va mentaliser le ciel, puisqu'il pointera vers le haut,
à vous abonner à la chaine avant de partir, si ce n'est pas déjà fait.
Et rendez-vous demain à 17H.
Ciao !